o pessoal vocês nem sabem o que é que eu
encontrei hoje que no estúdio fez não só
é um unicórnio mágico issão unicorn
quadro de pessoal de quem falou da crise
no haiti o que é coaching nós vamos
fazer é pessoal vai ser uma coisa muito
boa nisso que a mística homens de quem
estava certo não vai ser um grande
player não vai ser um blog não vai ser
nada disso vai ser um vídeo reação por
conta de nosso cinema e vamos ver o que
nós eu acho que foi o primeiro filme que
eu não sinto eu senti mesmo medo de
pagar é caipira jeito que eu dê 100%
algodão o campeão europeu foi boa em
goiás
nós vamos ver esse filme tipo aconteceu
foi coisa de paranormais de congonhas
são branson em samsung lançou o filme
foi baseado em factos que não é por um
entendimento e fui mesmo eu o banheiro
no filme acaba por isso algumas fotos
quando não é o caso no qual o caso
berlim e qual não é o caso do brasil
ontem quando nós chegamos a casa tipo
nós vamos investigar as coisas do
paranormal e pensarmos tempo depois um
veículo dirigido por não saber tudo o
que nós vamos fazer é ver no youtube os
vídeos rompimentos paranormais qantas já
por si câmeras ocultas questionou os
fantasmas é época e estamos no hotel eu
acho que vai acontecer com estoque eu em
tu vai pra onde ela vai te empurra
ajustar-se nem aí cadeira é então já
espera de alguma equipe rosa se não era
o cara na mesa o que aconteceu eu
estragar o show de alguma coisa faltou
meu deus eu acho que não é o uso de
traje que ter um pai de que um dia eu
não sou eu mas todo apoio ora a outra
mesmo gols do time
angus é um jovem
ai ja vi este extremo não meu
distribuidora agora eu acho que o
aeroporto por essa luta bené não pó ea e
é tão conveniente
olha só a calma calma ela vai pôr-se de
pé
olha ai dá muito medo era estranho é
[ __ ] é o que ri me que ele não sai é um
é qualquer coisa de ruim em 2006 não se
vê [ __ ] nenhuma tático todos um
paranormal é feito com uma batata
eu sabia que me pareço meta posse de
jorge bittar era uma meta pouco no meio
da floresta custo te recorda o índice
teve [ __ ] não só isso não seria
interessante porque as câmeras de
segurança câmeras de segurança em que a
minha experiência não é nada ter
infecções já que é nada diferente em que
software e funk é isso que eu acho um
luxo que é para garantir que isto coisa
mas no final valeu ou não isso é falso
na próxima eu que sou eu mas mesmo com
tanta coisa e gravar alguém está a
filmar um monitor com a quebra em quatro
plataformas de tecnologia por aqui o que
é isso é que eu ia andando andré ligou
eu não preciso voltar a filmar a janela
se está a filmar um monitor
eu não consegui entender a al atar funk
está fantasma mil fantasmas que é
fantasma real fica dentro de casa está
na espanha pela rua tá fácil eu não fui
irritar não tem um gênio registro não
foi mas tem um sim das ong e olha joel
joana não contém nenhuma não vai abrir a
porta eu vai entrar e vai ver o fantasma
e 2 que vai seguir corre e isso não foi
dada atenção é óbvio vai passar porque o
polícia olha eu ia fantasma se do meu
quarto a cair agora que vai acontecer
pronto agora vais embora fantasmas
eu também né a agora eu sou motion lá
olha só olha no que deu a seguinte nós
mostrando agora ai ai ai
as fugas buscava acho que a viola que eu
não sei porque todas as montagens ponto
vamos ficar assim
isto sim é uma assombração olha para a
extinção não suponha se encontravam
dentro do elevador
eu estou à espera maior da sua escola
já falei que não queria conhecer melhor
o rio gols até cá o número 22
ela pontuou ir pra onde para a etapa
mesmo placar da equipe assumir o leme
piu piu piu borravam total e não não viu
meu a reação dela real
eu não sei porque é fácil estar na mesma
distância faz um tempo mas para a câmera
mas a reação dela foi goiás no ina
portanto não sair eu não saí é assim que
eu sei se isso acontecesse em mim ou
analógica nos regimes de meta
eu não estava aqui era um [ __ ] número 1
ou seja estão baixas um grosso vídeo de
paranormalidade supostamente é um bebé é
um som brasil espera passar bandas
rápido à web ea bebê para fazer um bar o
euro apontou
como é que ele sabe que é um bebê e uma
sombra não é um benéfico e só que nem
vinha a o canhoto o fato de seu bebê
eu acho que é um bumbo vermelho
acho que não só eu sou bom o homem quem
é que vai ser a noite num bada e leva o
bebê não sair mas está mal explicado a
cair só se vocês souberem coisas mais
assombrosas mais fiéis nem pra nós
insistirmos mãe por o twitter informando
impuro em maio tipo contar com o
atacante é isso como as flec favorito
fica a ideia de aproximando